my god introduce yourself for the
audience
sure I'm Zack wood I'm singing a
producer at Sony Santa Monica all right
cool this is hokum stay close this is a
nice sorbet palate cleanser to the Hilda
is it would you say it's more difficult
or less difficult than this last mission
this game is a hundred percent
stress-free okay
one hundred percent so yeah you're this
you're this character this curious
technical or flying and we call in the
long mover and it's really just a game
about exploration and discovery and a
lot of surprises okay so like in this
environment this is called fun fair
which is sort of themed around you know
parties it's probably the busiest most
kind of bustling place we have in the
game so these characters as I fly past
them they jump up my back and they want
to go places and do stuff so I just kind
of fly them around and so the other is
so the game is is like 17 different
worlds and every world has their own
cast of characters and objective things
to do so there is kind of like a main
thing to do in every world but it's not
super outfit like it's not presented to
the player as soon as you come into a
place it's like you know kind of reveals
itself to you over time Sheriff
I'm I'm just so relaxed just looking at
this game all the troubles in my life
are just kind of fading away you can
really kind of get lost in it like here
I can these guys will jump off they want
to get into the ferris wheel and then I
can spin the ferris wheel up but it's
kind of swinging around it and this
little piece flew off alright so I can
go and pick that guy up
if you guys have any questions about the
game and Rick Tate has the twitch chat
over there so that piece turned into a
rollercoaster so this level here how
does this fit in sequentially is this
like the beginning of the game it's it's
nonlinear no you can go anywhere anytime
and it's not gated by completing of a
particular world you just go and travel
and explore or all of it at any time
okay like this one here I'm trying to
find these characters that match the
statues and then it gave me another one
of these pieces that I can take back to
the controls are really simple you just
move with the analog stick left analog
stick you can speed up with the X button
you can slow down with the circle button
and that's that's really it you can also
get a little boost of speed by wiggling
the stick I'm in for it
so you're really kind of like this
expressive thing yeah
but everything has kind of a reaction in
some way so this level that we're in
here you mentioned that you don't really
find the objectives at first right you
kind of have to like explore around so
give us an example of like what a kind
of like typical activity or objective I
hesitate to even call them objectives
yes even what it is in this game so like
the example was well here I'll do
another one so here there are these
lights that are a little bit gray and
some electricity here so I can
electrocute myself and turn these lights
on so you can see if they all turn on
like a reaction there
it's kind of cool it the user won't be
able to hear this but now the viewers
well feed there's the electricity comes
out of the speakers at the ps1 oh yeah a
little control on speaker is there any
of the touchpad yeah it's kind of a work
in progress right now but basically you
can interact with the with the player
this way oh and it actually records what
I just did it'll just keep playing it
until I let go so I can do things like
you know we'll figure a metal kind of
follow my pattern
I'll do obstacles so this game being
nonlinear and being kind of I mean it's
a very abstract game very
non-conventional game
what kind of is there any sense of
overarching progression to the game as
you kind of move from one area to the
next do you have the sense that you are
building up to some type of conclusion
or anything yeah yeah so one thing we
haven't really shown yet we can talk a
little bit about is that there's this
this sort of thread of a game of
hide-and-seek that sort of runs through
the entire game so you start out in the
space with a lot of your friends that
kind of look like you and they all jet
off to all these different spaces
yeah and so when you complete you know
kind of like the main activity in each
world then that friend of yours revealed
himself and goes back to this like home
world so there is kind of like and at
the very end you'll gather back though
your friends and sort of like restart
you know a game of hide and seek so that
that's kind of the connective tissue
it's not really a story per se right but
yeah
so by just turning all those lights on I
have another piece to the roller coaster
here
at what point do you ever come to the
realization that you you're done with a
particular environment you've kind of
done everything that you can do here
yeah yeah we can be can kind of do that
so in this one it's about the roller
coaster for finding all the pieces if I
can kind of show you what that looks
like here's the tail piece
yeah there is sort of a celebration are
you doing kind of like the main thing
so these cars that are need to find the
missing characters there so I'm missing
one of this purple guy and the yellow
guy
this is one of those games where you
just meet personally I would just died
to be a fly on the wall during like the
picture process of this it's like okay
so check it out guys
you're a line there's a purple guy
there's a yellow guy the pieces of the
roller coaster are missing but don't
worry we're gonna get them back
also the music is awesome but yeah
that's Hohokam there you go and then it
becomes a PlayStation 4 game yep that's
pretty much it yeah we've had our eye on
this game for a long time they have a
honey slug and Richard Hager the
co-creators of the game we saw this game
back in at IGF or like 2011 yeah so
we've been talking to them for quite a
while and they're familiar with the
kinds of games we make it Santa Monica
and sort of you know I think we're we're
known for you know kind of helping to to
help teams that kind of realize what
their vision is yeah we don't you know
we're very supportive in that way and
that's always been one of the things
that's been really cool about Sony's
approach to indie games over the years
it's not just the action-oriented indie
games like Sony has given a lot of
support to those very artsy abstract
games the that game company type of
approach to to stuff so it's it's nice
to see this trend continuing on the
PlayStation 4 yeah we're we're really
excited about it too and and you know
these are the kinds of games that really
motivate us you know kind of like
boundary-pushing innovative you know
sort of not the norm right this is the
kind of stuff that inspire this is oh
yeah it's in there a lot of fun to work
on
how's the chat doing Erte doing all
right yeah doing pretty good
is there another environment you can
show yeah sure
bounce around this is one it's called
kite world so you'll see kind of the the
the sense of every space being very very
different even though there's a
connective like art style to it yeah
it's like in this one if I run past
these like spinning trees they're kind
of like doorbells and they these people
pop out they jump with my back here and
they pick up these sort of pinecone
looking things and so if I take these up
to the mountains they'll turn them into
kites
and so that's kind of like the main
right think of this as well
the music's pretty key to the to the
experience too we were it was
interesting because like early on when
the guys were conceptually eyes in the
game they had a playlist of different
artists from mostly international the
record label and we reached out to him
and now we're collaborating with them on
this on the soundtrack for the game so
all of the music in hello con these
artists on the ghostly label so it's
artists like Shino taiko and Chicano and
mishneh and Ben Benjamin so that's been
really awesome we can kind of come full
circle and actually work with some of
the musicians that inspired you know the
early designs of the game so that's been
really awesome
this must be rude a tricky game to demo
because it's very different it's very
you know it's very expressionist and I'm
sure that you must get a lot of
different reactions from a lot of
different people huh yeah I tend to like
what we've been at trade shows or
whatever I tend to not explain it first
I just kind of like pass the controller
yeah check it out yeah because I think
it does a better job than I could ever
really you know in like a couple of
lines like describe it you know and yeah
people just kind of tend to get lost in
it you know and even if they don't know
what they're doing you know they just
sort of seem to have a good time that's
that's the kind of reaction we'd hope
for you know
it's all she'll show one more area just
kind of share variety here this is
called the guano Factory it's an quano
factory so these guys collect this this
new liquid is that guano is he
collecting one or okay that's fine you
know to each his own so what they do
that's what happens in the guano Factory
so you collect some of this stuff and I
can come down here fill up this bat I
can travel down these tubes
- wake up something lazy drones -
they're all falling asleep
it is one of those is mesmerising kind
of games where yeah I know I'm hosting
right now and I should be talking hmm
but it's also very easy to zone out just
kind of go no I don't know yeah I play
it every day I'm working on it and the
end time just goes by in the Attic oh my
god what time is it
yeah you just sort of get lost in it and
the music in the sound and the artworks
so beautiful it just kind of like takes
you away
now I can go down this one that is a lot
of guano that is not that is a
significant see I think I think the
question we get the most is what it you
know yeah well it looks really amazing
but what what are you doing you know
hopefully it's the kind of thing where
you know people see us playing like this
right and and when we show it you know
people can walk up and play it and
really understand what it's about
there's the line that you're controlling
is I have a a sense of momentum or are
you in a constant pinpoint surgical
control of it no no I mean there's
there's a bit of momentum to it and then
I can I can speed up and also I can kind
of get a little momentum here okay
speed along oh yeah
yeah it's pretty cool so is there is
there anything else that you wanted to
show here any other environment so I
feel like that gives no this is look
these are the three that we have right
now okay
yeah I think I shows how each space is
very different from the other yeah and
what you're doing in every world is also
very different from the last yeah so
cool so yeah give us the rundown on it
when is it coming out is it ps4 only is
it other Sony platforms no it's it's ps4
ps3 and Vita okay and it supports cross
save so you can save and resume on any
platform and we don't have a release
date yet but it's coming very very soon
a lot we're in the we're in the
homestretch so cool all right well thank
you for coming by and give us a little
taste of Hohokam and a little bit of the
taste of guano as well thanks